where that's like the only indicator of
of women's success but that's not it
um
okay so my next question how
old
is too old to be dating
for men and for women
i'm too loved
no i'll go
what does that mean yeah like okay
you know when someone's in the nba right
and they're playing yeah
they're going hard you know they're in
their 20s in their 30s they're chilling
at some point
people are going to look and say you are
too old to be here
and so for men and for women how old
because i know that manosphere will talk
about
men age better they do
but i think at some point too
men in a way need to hang up the jersey
i know that's not going to be popular
with my audience but at some point like
the club lights go off so
yeah
yeah um
what age what age
you know what to be fair
let's start with the guys i think it's
different for everyone
you want to retire when you want to
retire um
i think if you've established
what you've needed
when you're coming up like so you've got
your kids
all right you know maybe a relationship
didn't work out yada yada but dating
date in what's the intention after say
50
for a guy what what what are you hoping
to get at 50
i think i'm ready to just
coronation street it and just chill out
and just you know you've got your long
longtime
someone you know that you just survived
with and
you know you hook up once in a while but
i i don't see me
sitting at the table oh it's nice to
meet you on a date over 50. did you have
you just said
do you hear me just saying no probably
not when he hits 50 i'm just saying it
for the younger people
when he's 50 he's just looking for
someone to chill and hook up with right
and that's that older man
so when you're at 50 you're not looking
for like anybody to settle down because
you've got everything you want you don't
want anybody like over 35 you don't want
anybody your age
you want just want someone to hook up
with yeah and if you're going to hook up
with somebody it's going to be somebody
younger it's going to be okay it's gonna
be and then you can just check the chat
just i've one two things
yeah but for a female
i don't know
i don't know
probably sooner
so put an age what do you could say it
put an age i'm just trying to think of
an age
you know what i i don't know i'm going
to tell you why because i don't know
what a
48 year old woman's looking for at 48. i
don't know what are you looking for like
what's your question
what are we looking for yeah maybe you
know what that's it it's a learning what
are you looking for at 50 years old i'm
not looking for nothing because i'm all
right but i know that people are out
there looking for what are they looking
for what they can't get what they should
have been looking for at 30 and 25. okay
and i was just thinking about that
question my answer is
what age do you stop dating
every single parent when your children
leave primary school
okay
whatever age it is once your children
all finish primary school they move on
to secondary school don't bother
right because no man want no man come on
you don't mind having somebody with
kids at primary school yeah
but you don't want to be dating somebody
and they were like because i heard
somebody on one of your shows like oh
it's all right when there's a 17 year
old next door you know you don't want
that
definitely don't worry so as far as i'm
concerned it's not the age of the purse
of the woman
it's as she's got children
when your children is primary school
don't even think about dating
just wait for old man to hook you up
right so so yeah so just going back it
depends what where what we're calling
dating dating
we call it what
it's almost like the question is like
when because
i think that love is a young person's
game yeah and at some point you're not
really dating like to find love anymore
it's just to find something that works
so
i'm not phrasing this in the best way
but like when
when is it just
we're just gonna hook up because we're
both in the same place looking for the
same thing fine let's do it i don't want
to die alone and what
yeah so what like that's one and then
there's another point where you fall in
love you get married and have kids
when when is retirement okay right so if
i'm single and i've got no children
i am never retiring this is what i'm
saying to you okay men don't retire men
don't retire yeah they don't retire 65
70. no they don't
think they still want to pass on their
legacy whether they're going to be there
for five minutes perfect
yeah right they're out so depending on
your situation if you have a family
you've created children you've created
your legacy your children are thriving
successful then
you know you're not really looking today
you're just doing your thing
managers doing this thing you know what
do you think i don't know i had a
question regarding like um
so you see the way you were saying how
well you guys kind of like encourage
women to like
marry when they're younger maybe not my
age but like
as young as possible
um what about when guys get to um
what about when we now grow up do you
know what i'm saying like what's
stopping men from
sorry
stuff it meant from
looking at other women
i'll answer that one because i'm in a
long-term relationship
and i love my woman so i'm at a age
where
this person understands me
she's agreeable she's submissive
i'm not controlling her i don't do
control i don't tell you what to do but
we have an understanding you know what i
like you know what i don't like i know
you like you know
where am i going like because there
comes a time where it's
you know
another woman i don't even want to be
crude it's just another vajayjay with
another problem and issues that i'm not
prepared to deal with
so i'm just doing my thing i'm just
making sure that i'm into the mind sorry
i'm just making sure that i'm thriving
i'm trying to be successful for me and
my family because that's now my family
and i'm responsible for them all you
know so
that's
that's kind of
if you're
giving your man
what he needs and his understanding i
think
you know you
you should be all right but it depends
on what level of man you're looking for
so if you're looking for this mr high
value
you know i've got money i jump on jets
i've got a business call i'm going to be
spending the night in toronto then
you know what you're going to get well
that's why some girls like nba wives
they know their men are cheating they
know he's got five sides
and i don't feel bad for any of them
like that girl that was dating jason
derulo
and she wanted to come out and cry
because jason derulo cheated on her what
did you think you were gonna get you
dated jason derulo
even even ugly face wayne rooney
he was with the old woman prostitute
the old woman is miss is still there
he's been found numerous times
high value he is he generates millions
even though he's not even playing
football anymore she's not going nowhere
wish
she she knows what the deal is women
will stay over for legacy
right they understand right i'm creating
legacy see my children them just being
rooney
yeah opens doors for them yep and and
they're looking for that's what women
are looking for you're looking for the
prize to breed
your children to be successful and be
you know well that's why the the
you know being a single mother is like a
woman's mating strategy because she gets
the the genes from the first guy and
then she gets the parental investment
from the second guy
there you go so it's like a mating
strategy
so what age
after all that
so the age to like stop dating um
i'd say for men
i do agree in terms of that there's
become a point where it's like okay you
may have like all the money and all that
kind of stuff but it's kind of like
uh
um i'd say for men like
maybe like 45.
you said i would date a 45 year old
uh you're 21 right i probably wouldn't
have about twenty yeah yeah
but it's kind of it's kind of weird
there's a weird thing that happens at
like 23 to like 26 where you're like our
dad's hot
like it's over it's a really weird phase
but i promise you it'll happen one day
because when i was 21 when i heard a guy
that was 30 i was like oh grow like i
can't do 30. and then now i'm like
i could do 45 like that's fine
i don't know i don't maybe i haven't
reached that point yet but um
yeah i don't know i say for men like 45
because personally i wouldn't date
someone that's 45 years old that's way
too old for me but um
women
when do you stop dating
um
what would i say i'd say like
we're 45 so what are women going spit it
out
i'd say like
i'd say 40
40 okay okay yeah
i can't put an age on both of them i
can't put an age on it
okay 60.
too old to be there it's just like why
would you stop stating like if you
haven't found your person while you
still
i'm saying for love like when is love
off the table
i don't know if i believe in love i
don't know if i believe in love i think
it's just a
compromise
for regardless of what age i think it's
a compromise
i don't know about love okay what do you
think
i'm just sure that's so sad i believe in
love
um
yeah i said what i thought about primary
school once you got kids once they got
pregnant once you got kids at primary
school then once they've left stop
dating
because there's no point but if you're
single you've got no children
okay
prettier yeah
for men oh you said no men they can go
on forever never never um i think
men
at the age of
i'm gonna say 60 for men
i i give you 60. yeah i give you 60. as
long as you're like
in shape you got your [ __ ] together yeah
and that 60s a good time to
if you're not in a long-term
relationship
yeah
but women
and we're talking about love we're not
just talking about any random thing
we're talking about you start looking
i'd say about like
yeah this is tough in it
[Music]
like we're talking about like this woman
hasn't been in a relationship so she
hasn't got like
yeah single single yeah widowed no no no
we don't oh nobody okay then uh
sing one of the fifty percent of women
that are single and childless over
thirty
yeah maybe maybe forty yeah maybe you
would say forty seven maybe i'm gonna
say four
yeah maybe maybe
that's what i would say 35 32 33 okay
i'll give you i give them like
nah i reckon they could still have it at
33.
oh no no
no no
visualizing so much no i am i'm
literally like thinking of examples yeah
that'd be tough yeah